vous lui presque 10% de plus et je ne
l'imaginais pas avant cette élection
donc c'est une vibration avec ma ville
et je prends ce message comme un message
de confiance donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut continuer ce travail de terrain
qu'on qu'on accomplit depuis quelques
temps mais c'est aussi je pense une
vision nationale aussi je crois qu'il
faudra qu'on en parle est bien évident
qu'il y a dans ce dans ce scrutin est
également la sanction d'une politique
est menée au niveau national ex-aequo
non seulement vous êtes porté va par
votre bilan de maire sortant mme il ya
aussi cette vague qui vous pousse vous
même vous nous disiez juste avant
l'antenne que vous étiez même surpris de
ce score les cantines s p diddy
sans aucune autre court pas résolu non
simplement j'ai évoqué le fait que c'est
quand même un signe très fort de ce que
les françaises et les français
comprennent un message est que un député
ump qui puisse à présent l'ump et un
score pareil dans sa ville ça laisse
supposer qu'au niveau national il y aura
sûrement des scores aussi important et
on disait tout à l'heure on parlait de
montbard je pense qu'il ya ici en côte
d'or beaucoup de villes qui sont
concernés 1 on peut parler de montbard
on veut parler de plombières on peut
parler aujourd'hui du score même de
quétigny des des villes comme celle ci
ça laisse augurer probablement d'autres
nouvelles dans la soirée y compris à
dijon